wir reden aber jetzt erstmal über die
katholischen kirche ja wir kommen
sozusagen zum messwein ich will gold nun
mal nicht über corona sondern über die
andere pandemie und die andere pandemie
ist der missbrauch von kindern in der
katholischen kirche das ist der
bleibende größte sündenfall in der
geschichte der kirche und vielleicht
einer der größten in der geschichte der
menschheit unglaublich das aufsichts
befohlene mit religion erziehung
befasste menschen sich an kindern
vergriffen haben im schutzraum kirchen
unglaublich jetzt rast die kirche auch
ungebremst auf den abgrund zu also die
amtsgerichte kommen gar nicht mehr
hinterher
termine für den für den kirchenaustritt
anzubieten und es sind gerade noch 12
prozent der deutschen der meinung dass
man großes vertrauen in die katholische
kirche hat kann von den katholiken sind
sie übrigens auch nur 29 das ist
verheerend die trauen ihrer eigenen
kirche nichts mehr zu so aber
konsequenzen hat in der kirche niemand
gezogen der erste der jetzt was mal
gesagt hat sich aus der deckung getraut
hat war der münchner kardinal marx der
gesagt hat er könne sich schon
vorstellen dass manche priester
verheiratet besser aufgehoben wären aber
da kann man ja sicher sein dass
scheitert wieder an rom sowie andere
reformvorschläge auch die sind über
jahrzehnte immer wieder an rom
gescheitert deshalb sage ich jetzt mehr
die katholische kirche vor dem untergang
retten will der muss sie neu gründen er
muss eine kirche haben die erstens den
zölibat auf gibt die
dafür sorgt dass priester heiraten
können und zwar auch
gleichgeschlechtlich die dafür sorgt
dass frauen priesterin wären
bischöfinnen und texten da darf gar
nichts ausgeschlossen sein die außerdem
geschiedene wiederverheiratete und denen
nicht die sakramente verweigert was sie
bisher tut und die dann noch als letztes
dafür sorgt fünf punkte sind für mich
die als letztes dafür sorgt dass schwule
und lesben in der kirche auch getraut
werden können dann wäre die kirche im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert angekommen
und ich glaube dass die kirche und der
glauben die sakramente die gottesdienste
alles das man was man an riten und
traditionen in der kirche kennt sollten
erhalten bleiben da bin ich überhaupt
nicht dagegen das ist eine frage der
katholiken wenn sie das wollen sollen
sie es weitermachen also würde ich ihnen
sagen verändert nur die schale in der
glauben aufbewahrt wird und die schale
muss unbefleckt seien die schale ist für
mich die organisierte kirche und ohne
eine neugründung geht es nicht ist das
naiv ist das
todesmutig so was zu fordern völlig
sinnlos ich glaube es nicht ich glaube
dass grund stürzende veränderung immer
illusionär erschienen sind am anfang
dann hat sich doch viel verändert ich
hoffe sehr darauf dass sich menschen
finden die so was in angriff nehmen das
könnte ja dann zum beispiel schon damit
anfangen dass die kirche sind nämlich
auch ihrem buch zu den reichsten
organisationen weltweit gehört und die
kirche könnte mal etwas von ihrem
reichen er und ich meine dass man einen
sehr das machen sie jetzt offenbar um
ich möchte auch mal also klaus sie heute
als ehemaliger spd weder auf der
offenbar mich jetzt als christlich
gläubiger zahlen übrigens ohne
kirchensteuern ein evangelisches zahl
auch aus überzeugung die kirchensteuer
und ich zahle sie weiß beispiel die
kirche kindergärten fördert ich war auf
einem streng katholischen nasen es wurde
auch von der kirche von malteser
gefördert ich bin aus überzeugung
christin und aber aus überzeugung zahle
ich auch die kirchensteuer
dementsprechend meine frage uli müssten
vielleicht alle katholiken evangelisch
werden bei uns ist immer gewartet
eine fünf punkte
wenn man gerichtlich stoppen
zuspitzen wenn ich danach würde ich
sagen du möchtest das war sie alle
evangelischen habe in idyllischen per
heirat ja die china sind nach ihrem
ganzen
acht jahre ich habe ausdrücklich gesagt
der glauben der ritus die gottesdienste
die traditionen sollen so bleibt
mexikanische gottesdienst vor allem
zusammen geht nicht um die ökumene mir
geht es darum dass die dass der
katholische glauben hat ein glaubens
inhalt der die marienverehrung
beispielsweise findet in der
evangelischen kirche überhaupt nicht das
sollen die alles behalten da will ich
überhaupt nichts dann verändern sondern
die sollen ihre schande
seitigen die katholiken sollen dafür
sorgen dass diese in schande geratene
kirche gereinigt wird und alles andere
sollen sie behalten die evangelische
kirche ist in ich war mal evangelisch
die ist für mich so verwechselbar und
mit was ist uns mit allem also ich hab
mal das letzte was sie erlebt haben war
eine taufe in im berliner dom im
seitenschiff da ging es zu wie im
kindergarten da war ein einziges
geschrei da muss ich da bin ich dann
raus
frage ich doch gar nicht dann kann es ja
evangelischen habe ich nichts dagegen
aber die ist mir zu beliebig also wenn
ich heute wieder ein kirche eintreten
müsste wird oder wollte würde ich wohl
überlegt ohne diese schale die ist mir
befleckt da nämlich nichts mehr zu tun
haben würde ich was glauben ritus und so
weiter angeht ernsthaftigkeit der
religion muss ich mal sagen in die
katholische kirche ist macht verschafft
wenn man sich zu sehr streiten aber wm
definitiv klaus gedanken aber nicht ganz
falsch weil vieles was du geschrieben
hast ist ja so eine evangelischen kirche
die evangelische kirche wurde auch
gegründet weil die menschen mit der
katholischen kirche nicht mehr der koran
nicht wegen der sexualmoral das haben
sicher abspeichern interessante aber das
ist doch inzwischen das wird doch in der
inter katholischen kirche weithin
diskutiert das was ich vorgeschlagen
wird alles wird diskutiert wird
gefordert inzwischen erzengels inserent
er inzwischen ist der final in münchen
dafür dass priester heiraten dürfen es
gibt einen einen dialog prozess ein
reformprozess dass der sogenannte
synodale weg dann eben auch bischöfe da
wird alles was ich eben aufgezählt habe
diskutiert weil die selber sehen wenn
sie es nicht tun gehen sie zu grunde die
menschen wenden sich eltern dazu also
ich finde das schreit eigentlich danach
dass sich die beiden kirchen wieder
vereinigen
weil das seelische kirche mit dem marien
glauben und der heiligenverehrung der
boden also ich meine der glaube ist eine
sehr persönliche angelegenheit und man
kann ja diese marienverehrung ist ja
jedem selbst überlassen
aber das was sie fordern also neuer wein
in alten schläuchen oder oder oder wer
auch immer das passiert aber nicht wenn
ich wenn ich wenn ich sage ich ich hebe
das zölibat auf ich lasse frauen zu
kirchenämtern zu das ist ja tatsächlich
das was in der ich bin katholisch
gewesen das ist natürlich genau das was
in der evangelischen kirche stattfindet
aber es wäre doch an ken großartige
gedanke wenn diese beiden kirchen wieder
zusammenfinden würden
und ich meine das ist natürlich auch in
finanziell nichts sagen wie ich kann mit
dem 2002 bin ja das ist alles richtig ja
das meine ich auch deutschland für
deutschland ist bestimmt alles richtig
aber die katholische kirche ist ja quasi
internationaler deshalb macht es ja auch
nicht angenommen und ehrlich gesagt ist
katholischen kirche deutschland also ich
will nicht sagen egal aber es ist jetzt
nicht ihre vordringlichste platz sondern
ist lateinamerika die kirchensteuer ja
natürlich ich will aber nicht ein punkt
ich finde diese
réunion irgendwie faszinieren gedanken
ich wollte man noch was zu den menschen
in der katholischen kirche sagen die
sich da beheimatet fühlen die da
ihr leben zum teil ganz verbracht haben
und so was der absolut überwiegende teil
der menschen in der katholischen kirche
fast keine kleinen kinder an das
vergewaltigt keine einer der absolut
libero meter sowie ausgewiesene vier
hubs angaben schon gehabt ich gehe so
dass ich wünsche mir ich kann es nicht
beweisen aber glaubt sogar der
überwiegende teil aller priester in der
katholischen fast ja auch keine kleine
anderen nein das macht neben einzelfall
nicht besser ich
bleibe noch einmal eine kerze an ernten
für all diejenigen ihrer überzeugung aus
nächstenliebe aus wir müssen für die
älteren menschen die heizkosten
übernehmen das könnte auch eingegangen
der gemeinde sein und ich bin sicher da
draußen in deutschland gibt es gemeinden
durch solche gedanken gedacht werden für
all diejenigen die durch diese
unfassbaren missetaten in
mitleidenschaft gezogen werden weil
dieses wärmegefühl sie empfinden dadurch
geschändet ist
mit denen bin ich mit meinen gedanken
auch bei denen ich gehofft auch die
wende ich doch in der hand liegt der
sich heute sage ich doch die muss ja
eine neue kirche aus der kirche
gegründet von solchen gern haften läuten
wir sehen das inzwischen so weit dass
ein papst beim nur er gestorben ist ein
papst hat offensichtlich gelogen man hat
dann und werden auch nie gelogen hat und
wohl der der held die heim-wm papst
dreher aber das ist nicht auch noch
kommt
wir hatten ja wir hatten ja auch diese
pädophilen fälle auch in anderen ländern
irland australien usa kanada eigentlich
überall leider und die katholische
kirche ist ja eigentlich dafür bekannt
seit hunderten von jahren sie hat kriege
mitgetragen bei den nazis mit dabei hat
er gar nicht an ihren noch mehr dabei
ist
damals wurden kriege geführt wurden
menschen verbrannt und die hat sich nie
wirklich mit ruhm bekleckert und es ist
eine bereichen verein unterwelt wieder
mal ganz ehrlich wenn die auch in time
wenn sie wirklich diese nächstenliebe
leben würde den könnten ihr ins geld
ausschütten an die armen kinder in
afrika an diejenigen die nicht reizen
können et cetera pp nein die stapeln ihr
geld haben noch finanzskandale mit dem
vatikan bank und so weiter ich sie
vergessen so ein bisschen die die kultur
oder auch die erdung die man auch
empfindet und ich muss ehrlich sagen
dass das hier auch was mit tradition zu
tun hat und ich finde wenn man es immer
alles so schlecht macht ich dann ist man
eigentlich gegen jeden der dort auch er
dann eine erlaubnis gut jeder kann sein
glauben haben also ich ich brauche die
kirche nicht für glauben ich kann
trotzdem an etwas glauben ich glaube
einfach der die kirchen sind ein
unternehmen das sind unternehmen der
seit 1000 jahren gut läuft die beste
business plan der welt würde ich jetzt
mal sagen ja sie nutzen ihre macht aus
schamlos aus und deswegen bin ich kein
fan der kirche war seit jeher immer
unrecht entstand so weil ich glaube dass
viele menschen
einen glauben brauchen und ihn suchen
und die frage ist ob er noch geboten
wird ob also derjenige der ihn anbietet
in diesem fall die katholische kirche
glaubwürdig ist und das tun kann was die
kirchensteuer an geht übrigens oder du
tust das ist ja so als würde die kirche
aus ihrem vormann gefällt haben auch
wenn sie glauben tun sie sind ja
einen schönen abend bis morgen abend 20